the jurogan experience the worst thing
that can happen to a comic because you
get real soft because everybody loves
you and they go to see you
and they laugh at anything you say
that's one of the reasons why steve
martin said he stopped touring
right because steve martin when i was a
kid
let's get small was out and he would
come out with the bunny ears on and
like play the banjo [ __ ] he was so good
these kids today these [ __ ]
kids today they don't know
steve martin was a monster no they don't
know about that but they know they're
doing hell rooms nobody just
shows up what i mean oh i mean they
don't know how good steve martin was
like people forgot when steve martin was
doing a ring he wasn't doing i don't
know if he was doing no he did he did
like
nassau call us he got that big but he
was doing his albums
like they were so silly and so fun
and so different like he had a his own
unique style
you know and when he just felt like
anything he did they laughed at and he
lost track of whether or not it was good
or not
and he just stopped doing it and i
remember thinking when i was first
starting doing comedy i can't imagine
a that that could ever happen or b that
you can't there's not a work around
steve
you're the [ __ ] man i think it really
was he also had all these ideas for film
and all the stuff that he did
yeah um but you know it's kind of
interesting like
where he is where what he used to say
about
uh like i was such a serious time that
he was coming out of oh like you know
the previous decade all the
assassinations the vietnam war the gas
crisis and all that
and all these comics were talking about
all this heavy [ __ ] and he was just
super silly
they just was like a mental break um
somebody came to us uh with a um a pilot
idea for something
and it was over the top like absurd and
silly and like that was my
reference i'm going to this is like the
steve martin bunny ear thing everybody's
like going
with trump and and the virus and i don't
know and it's like this thing is just
silly there's no there's no me to cancel
call there's nothing in here you can
just sit down
like that dumb and dumber type of thing
that yeah that i love look at him
[Laughter]
do i tell you people people today
it's hard to appreciate how big he was
and i was a kid right
so that when when steve martin was huge
i mean what year was this
late 74 but yeah this is probably before
that too
yeah was he still doing comic comedy in
84 i thought he
i found a video that said it was a
stand-up performance from 84.
that's probably right around the time
when he stopped but i thought he stopped
before that
but when i was in high school was when
steve martin was just born
standing up he's got a great book that's
the book born standing up you know what
kills me as i loaned that to somebody
gave it up in 80. i never got it back
81. so he gave it up when i was a
freshman in high school
the book is great red band gave me the
book for uh christmas one year it's
really good
it's it's really interesting too because
like i said i don't i think
when you talk about like great comics of
all all these generations for whatever
reason
people just think of him as a great
movie star they think the jerk which is
unbelievably funny movie and all those
amazing movies that he did
yeah it was a great movie doesn't like
these kids
he was so good he was so silly what was
the mafia movie he played what was that
one when he
the guy oh yeah yeah yeah and he goes
into the supermarket
and he just he gets the price gun and
everything's like 99 cents he's kind of
standing there he's scanning all this
filet mignons and everything what was
that
yeah yeah rick rick miranda that was a
great [ __ ]
that bit that you did on side art live
about rick miranda's getting punched in
the face i was [ __ ] howling you know
i thought that if anything i thought
because everybody loves rick which i do
too of course i was just you know was
the place that's a joke catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience